bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las dos y cuarto por las redes
sociales en internet en esta emisión
conversamos sobre los temas destacados
de la semana y damos lectura a sus
comentarios y correos electrónicos
hoy les acompañan en los micrófonos un
luis laborda leonora chapman leonardo
gimeno y quienes habla ruso valencia en
la versión radio de este programa
disponible en nuestro sitio eres en el
punto o sea les presentaremos la música
de un dúo de voces colombianas elía y
elisabeth con el tema todo en la vida
les presentamos también el tema
propaganda del colectivo canadiense
dedicado al afro beat el grupo se llama
a frotis y nació aquí en montreal y
luego nos vamos al sur para escuchar al
grupo tanghetto electro tango cometiendo
la pieza gallo ciego bueno cometiendo
porque es tango electrónico así que eso
no les va muy bien a quienes aman el
tango antiguo bien
mataría a 6 metros de distancia
me gusta ya no me parece mal pero los
amantes del tango tradicional no pasa
pero eso es quedarse en el tiempo
uno puede amar al folclore a mí no me
gusta porque le combatiría con platillos
y con la guitarra electrónica me gusta
el tradicional no digo que lo otro esté
mal claro entonces si aparte de esta
breve introducción sobre el tango qué
temas les han llamado la atención esta
semana a mí me encanta la reacción de
los franceses con respecto al campeonato
del mundo y que la gente diga que gano
frank frica es decir francia y áfrica y
ahora parece que los jugadores y el
gobierno francés reniegan de la
procedencia de los jugadores
comparándolo con eeuu por ejemplo la
población negra eeuu es ellos se definen
como afroamericanos pero la población
negra de
de francia cuando no están en un lugar
visible como un equipo de fútbol son los
negros y en el caso de que ganaron son
franceses entonces esa diferencia y no
quieren decir que no quieren decir
salieron dos o tres jugadores a decir yo
soy francés no soy cabrones yo no soy
guineano yo no soy cuando en realidad
digamos en la sangre lo llevan y no es
despectivo para nada es absolutamente
formidable y es una demostración de
en la esencia de esa inmigración en
estos países pero parece que la agencia
en francia no está muy de acuerdo con
ese tipo de comentarios
justamente en mi página de facebook y
puse después de que ganó por una foto
inclusive indicando que ganó el mundial
lo que no áfrica
y además es una es algo lo dije en la
medida en que sin emigración no sería no
no no habría sido el mismo mundial y en
un contexto en que en europa hay vientos
fuertes y moss de corrientes anti
migrantes xenófobas basta ver lo que
está pasando en grecia por ejemplo donde
la policía no ni siquiera va a animarse
a hacer un proceso sobre los casos de
violencia contra los inmigrantes
entonces la idea de que el fútbol de esa
forma podría mostrar que finalmente está
la idea de la raza snap una invención
que no ayuda digamos a que las
sociedades puedan funcionar de manera
más orgánica y pacífica entre sus
distintos elementos habría que
preguntarle también a los franceses a
los jugadores de origen africano qué
piensan ellos que dicen ellos lo son y
yo los vi jugar en él al cantar el himno
francés antes de los partidos y había
mucha emoción
no estoy diciendo que no sea el francés
y digo en general es que salieron dos o
tres de estos jugadores
es de origen africano a decir que ellos
eran franceses que el africano tenía que
ver si tiene que ver a su padre o sea ni
siquiera pongámosle el color de la piel
de sus padres de su abuelo no tiene nada
que ver me parece exagerado que ellos se
sientan franceses a mí no me parece de
esa manera cada uno toma la identidad
que quiere tener es decir por supuesto
es como si mi hijo jugará en la
selección que no va a ser canadiense y
que la canadiense ganará alguna vez un
mundial que no va a hacer ni renegar de
sus raíces pero la respuesta a los
jugadores tiene que ver sobre todo con
críticas que se vienen arrastrando ya
desde hace tiempo mucho antes de mundial
hay que recordar que el año pasado ya el
año pasado marín de penn que no es
precisamente la mejor demostración del
debut de la democracia en francia había
dicho que ella no reconocía a francia en
esta selección precisamente porque el 80
por ciento y el 80 por ciento del
plantel francés que participó de mundial
es inmigrante de origen africano
y esta señora declaró como ha declarado
tantas cosas a lo largo de su existencia
que ya no reconocía a francia en ese
plantel entonces tal vez es una reacción
de los jugadores de reafirmación de su
identidad francesa porque de hecho
tienen la ciudadanía francesa viven en
francia y han competido defendiendo los
colores de separ y además creo que bueno
lepén pues ya sabemos ya conocemos su
ideología entonces lo que sí creo
importante es como los franceses
festejaron esta copa del mundo después
no creo que lo que sí no creo es que
esta copa del mundo ganada por franceses
de origen africano vaya a cambiar gran
parte de este pensamiento que se notó y
que tiene en gran parte de los polis no
digo de los políticos en la sociedad
pues también la francesa no ese
entusiasmo se va a terminar en algún
momento iban a seguir los problemas que
tiene francia quienes hemos tenido
alguna meta suerte de estar ya en
francia y hemos podido recorrer un poco
parís y sus alrededores sabemos lo que
son los gritos
es decir exacto los suburbios y hay la
integración es nula no efectivamente
habría que puntearon esos amigos les
preguntamos a ustedes cuál es su balance
del mundial si estuvo al nivel de sus
expectativas y sobre todo bueno cuál es
el dolor ron
que no haya habido ni un solo equipo
latinoamericano al final en por lo menos
unos cuartos de final
porque se juega en noviembre y diciembre
las canchas son de arena
una ventaja que los desplazamientos van
a ser muy cortos asociarse bueno yo el
rufo destacó una noticia esta semana que
me pareció importante en tanto que
canadienses de origen latinoamericano y
este este cambio ministerial de gabinete
que hubo esta semana en canadá el primer
ministro
y esto aportó unos cambios ya con vistas
a las elecciones en un año y medio se
llevarán a cabo aquí en canadá frente al
avance que está teniendo también el
partido conservador pues este este
cambio lo dicen los analistas tienen
muchísimo que ver con las próximas
elecciones y por primera vez hay un
canadiense de origen latinoamericano que
pasa a ser parte del gabinete estamos
hablando de juan pablo rodríguez que es
de origen argentino que desde hace ya
tiempo está es diputado de aquí de una
local y de una localidad no decir
construcción circunscripción gracias de
montreal y que ya viene teniendo cargos
en el nivel federal dentro del partido
liberal y que ahora heredó un ministerio
que creo que es muy importante que está
bastante caliente en este momento y que
es el ministerio del patrimonio
canadiense y del cual nosotros
dependemos es decir si vice radio canadá
somos parte también de este ministerio
de las comunicaciones entonces creo que
va a tener pues un trabajo bastante
duro que hacer sobre todo con las
cuestiones de netflix que eso fue un
conflicto que hubo aquí en canadá con la
anterior ministra scioli que estaba a
cargo de esa cartera y es un poco
brevemente para explicar es que netflix
en canadá pues el gobierno liberal había
decidido de no cobrar en los mismos
impuestos que le cobra a compañías
canadienses del mismo tipo también va a
tener el tema yo creo de los de la
prensa escrita que está cada vez
perdiendo terreno en fin creo que es un
ministerio pues muy importante que ha
heredado juan pablo rodríguez y la
historia de juan pablo rodríguez es
también parte del visto del exilio
argentino la salud pública no realidad
su padre julio rodríguez era también de
tucumán ha sido en argentina un abogado
defensor de presos políticos y que vino
en el año 75 en pleno auge de la
triple-a en argentina para la alianza
anticomunista argentina que pues en ese
momento atacaba a personas como julio
rodríguez abogado defensor de
los políticos y sindicalistas y pues
tuvo una bomba que le pusieron en su
casa bastante de un poder explosivo
mortal la suerte del era que las que en
los dormitorios estaban detrás y no
adelante todo el frente fue destruido
eso era una de las tantas amenazas que
recibió julio rodríguez entonces pues en
el 75 vinieron a canadá a ir como
refugiados no y él era un abogado y
ahora el hijo se convirtió en ministro
de matrimonio entonces esa es una
historia pues de intenté la inmigración
finalmente ni el patrimonio justamente
es el ministerio que se encarga de las
instituciones culturales del país de
guardar la memoria de este proyecta
mente entonces yo creo que pues está muy
bien muy bien es de este nuevo ministro
y muy simbólico es un buen elemento yo
creo vamos a ver cómo lo resuelve
resuelve los conflictos la política
implica negociaciones alguien decía que
la política a veces implica comer el
sándwich que menos te gusta en fin bueno
dicen que la política es el arte de
negociar y a veces como el matrimonio
el sándwich
así que si louis hay que negociar
permanentemente tanto en el matrimonio
como en la política entonces a veces
aunque no estés de acuerdo y no te guste
sabes que por el bien ya sea de la
pareja o del país hay que dar pasos que
a veces no te gustan claro y para ti que
a mí lo que me llama la atención es un
hecho que incluso incluyen una de las
noticias de esta mañana que es a partir
de esta reunión de primeros ministros
que se está llevando a cabo en nuevo
brunswick se decidió algo que yo ni
siquiera sabía que lo iban a tener en la
mesa de negociación de discusión de
diálogo se decidió
hacer un poco menos severas las
restricciones al consumo y tratado de
alcohol de cerveza y alcohol en general
interprovincial porque mis precios más
baratos eliminar o exhibe la cantidad de
alcohol que una persona puede trabajador
entre una provincia y la otra porque
como supongo yo muchos de nuestros
residentes no sabrán y aunque suene un
poco extraño decirlo hasta edad sino muy
mucho tiempo era imposible en algunos
casos ingresar al alcohol comprado en
una provincia a otra provincia igual
por ejemplo exacto uno
yo conozco gente que lo hace
periódicamente digamos que vive justo al
límite y es más barato de aquel lado lo
pasa y también el tema es tiene que ver
un control para esa nueva vida con no
hay controles estrictos de la entrada
aquí toda la venta y la distribución de
alcohol en quebec es el gobierno
existentes que es lo mismo en las otras
si hay muchas ni siquiera limite a la
compra en otras provincias pero bueno
aquí es la sociedad el conde que ve que
si son en realidad es casi lo mismo la
misma entidad pero provincial década
pero para poner un ejemplo gráfico en la
época en la que yo comencé en esta radio
cuando para algunos colegas yo traía
algunas botellas de vino compradas en
ottawa a mitad de precio de lo que en
ese momento contaba el vino acá en
memoria real efectivamente yo estaba
infringiendo la ley
desde ontario a que yo lo supe después
de haberlo hecho yo fui una para para
unas fiestas fuimos con dos amigos
justamente ontario y 123 cajas cada uno
porque realmente bastante más barato y
cuando llegamos acá estamos una reunión
dije nada así porque nos fuimos a
ontario ahora pero no se puede
como no no no no se puede pasar de una
provincia a otra el límite provincial
no me agarraron más venimos nosotros los
nuestros países donde no existe absoluto
obviamente uno de uno recuerda aquello
de que en argentina por ejemplo no hay
aduanas internas y acá eso suena extraño
pero tiene que ver con una cuestión de
impuestos la provincia vende ese alcohol
a quien que ve por ejemplo es el estado
el que acapara la venta del alcohol
aunque hoy en día se consigue alcohol
también en algunos supermercados
etcétera pero el ingreso que obtiene la
saca la société des alcohol de quebec a
partir de la tasa de impuestos que cobra
con la venta de cada botella de vino de
cerveza o de lo que fuera constituye su
principal ingreso
muy bien entonces para mí el tema más
más más bueno ya está es una vieja
historia es este este permanente y circo
en la casa blanca con trump que llevó a
cabo una conferencia de prensa en
helsinki donde una sola palabra se
convirtió en tema de una empresa
política es wood y woods podría y no
podría entonces perdón entonces ese ese
tema y pues inclusive su propio el
responsable de la seguridad de
inteligencia eeuu se entera por
televisión en directo y en que supone
que debía saberlo con anticipación que
es trampa invitado a putin a putin a
digital en la casa blanca este próximo
otoño si igual no fue en la conferencia
en una reunión con putin que tiene que
desacreditó sus servicios de servicios
de inteligencia la cia el fbi no hacen
nada
básicamente hacia acá
así que es de alguna forma cuando camps
se vaya creo que va a perder ese encanto
del escándalo porque estamos curados
yo creo que sabe muy bien que el tema de
pan y circo funciona efectivamente nada
en donde de circo circo circo circo a la
historia sí aunque hay algunas
situaciones en las cuales ese circo
rayana con la vida mental en todo caso
no es cierto porque por ejemplo en las
cosas que sigue diciendo putin en
público lógico hace muy pocos días es
que sus padres de nacionalidad alemana
por ejemplo algo que es absolutamente
mentira de quién sí sí sí sí es verdad
él dice que es alemán pero la
documentación dice que no es verdad y es
su padre era alemán y vino de alemania
hizo y su abuelo es alemán antes lo
discuto entonces no tengo la menor idea
cuando se discutía de obama también que
no era estadounidense de nacimiento sino
de dónde era en las islas se dice
cualquier cosa bueno entonces en ese
punto acertó
yo no sé había un periodista del diario
le monde que recientemente también
explicaba un poco lo que sucedía con
este enigma que sigue siendo tal vez
para algunos
trump y él decía que metro por ejemplo
terminó con el siglo 20 le dio la vuelta
al cachetazo al siglo 20 al
multilateralismo está rompiendo con
organismos como la osce de la unión
europea está desde que asumió atacó a
dos países no irán a méxico pero hoy con
la elección de lópez obrador tiene una
actitud completamente diferente con
mexico es una actitud respetuosa y llama
la atención también esta actitud que
tiene con putin es decir en este momento
está como eligiendo sus dos grandes
amigos que es putin va a ser lópez
obrador y el resto viste está rompiendo
con todo el resto no entonces hay algo
acá que si yo creo que es muy coherente
con su pensamiento en el caso de las
relaciones con el personal doran llevó
inclusive
que podría preferir iniciar
negociaciones para un nuevo tratado
exactamente si para además envió a sus a
su gente cuando fue electo lópez obrador
yo creo que tiene mucho que ver con la
también con la cantidad de votos de esa
gran mayoría que arrasó lópez obrador
envió a su vicepresidente envió a su
yerno y todos y todos fueron muy mansos
a méxico y el que el que el que
organizaba el que el que dictaminaba en
la agenda fue lópez obrador eso es lo
que dicen los analistas en esas
historias cuando se vean juntos porque
por lo pronto el que comete los
exabruptos es él en persona claro si no
pero en este lo que quiero decir es que
cuando asumió tuvo una actitud muy
despectiva con peña nieto por ejemplo
pero de entrada y ahora ves que hay una
diferencia muy grande con lópez obrador
estos yo creo que hay que seguirlo al
tema hay que igual que las lecturas de
la de la expresión corporal con la
reunión en la reunión con putin
que no lo salud yo no lo saludo ni lo
sacudió como hizo con el 80 90 por
ciento de los primeros ministros y
presidentes de otros países que pareció
un osito frente a un gallo es la cosa
pero pues yo creo que no es nada loco
trump yo creo que sabe lo que está
haciendo imposible y sigue su ideología
no efectivamente están escuchando que
nada de las américas es café en radio
canadá internacional este programa está
también disponible nuestro programa en
nuestro sitio en internet eres en ese
punto sea y allí en la versión radio
queremos también música de colombia y
también de canadá ahora pasamos a los
temas centrales que recordar
recomendamos para esta semana tenemos
mensajes y antes un saludo
guillén abril le dice aquí en nuevo
brunswick podemos trasladar solamente un
litro de vino de la provincia de québec
un litro un litro pero a partir de cero
y aparte de este acuerdo se elimina ese
límite y se eliminan o se suaviza mejor
pero
en esta semana alex chapman tú
nos presentas a brenda mílner quienes
ella es una eminente neurocientífica y
es mi ídolo tengo que decirlo porque
cumplió 66
100 años la semana pasada y todavía va
tres veces por semana a la universidad
de mcgill a dar clases ya dirigida a sus
investigadores
ella es una neuropsicóloga profesora en
el departamento de neurología y
neurocirugía de magill y también es
profesora de psicología del instituto
neurológico de montreal es muy conocida
rufo por haber estudiado durante años a
un paciente que se lo conocía como h&m
y su trabajo pues pionero que la llevó a
descubrir cómo los cerebros humanos
retienen nuevos recuerdos ella empezó a
trabajar con este paciente que era un
paciente del doctor anfield
el original claro el original el
verdadero calibre el nombre es claro y
que el instituto muggle fue él el que
creó el belga en este instituto de
neurología claro ella trabajaba con él
eran su estudiante más que estudiante no
en temas que estudiante quiere decir ya
era profesora formada tenía un doctorado
y maggie y en fin y ella tomó a éste
hm que es este tenía 29 años sufría de
epilepsia y tenían unas convulsiones
tremendas entonces no había otra opción
en aquel entonces estamos hablando de
los años 50 le extirparon una parte del
cerebro como se hacía y las convulsiones
desaparecieron pero le crearon otros
problemas es decir problemas de recontra
recordar de cosas la memoria corta que
le dicen entonces ella
y decidió trabajar con él para ver
exactamente por qué decían este ya no no
no da más o sea se acuerda lo mejor
cosas del pasado
es imposible que tengas recuerdos que
aprenda cosas en el presente ella
decidió trabajar con él y entre otros
hizo experimentos con él y por ejemplo
yo vi una fotografía y un en youtube que
pasaban de magill el ex experimentos
experiencias ella le dé le puso un
espejo al frente en un momento dado con
un papel y un lápiz y le dijo que
dibujara un modelo de una estrella
entonces él mirando el espejo dibujaba
al día siguiente a la semana volvían a
enseñarle y él ni siquiera sé que
recordaba que había hecho eso ni que le
habían enseñado ni quién era ella porque
tampoco se olvidaba después que dejaba
eso se olvidaba de todo finalmente uno
una semana más unas semanitas más tarde
él ya era capaz de dibujar la estrella
sin saber que se le había enseñado antes
la práctica lo llevó y sin acordarse
quién era ella y entonces a través de
eso ella establecería su reputación como
una de las neurocientíficas más
importantes del siglo 20 y por qué
porque se dio cuenta que si aquel
descubrió que h&m podía aprender y
recordar determinados tipos de tarea y
que sus recuerdos del pasado anterior a
la operación estaban aparentemente
intactos eso importante es súper
importante lo que ella hizo y eso lo que
le llevó a ella a concluir después de
varios años que la memoria a largo plazo
y la memoria motriz el hecho de dibujar
están controladas por diferentes partes
del cerebro y eso fue lo que abrió la
puerta y con esto pues ella demostró que
las personas tienen múltiples sistemas
de memoria que gobiernan diferentes
actividades como el lenguaje o las
habilidades motoras y abriendo el camino
para una mayor comprensión de cómo
funciona el cerebro es
muy importante lo que ella descubrió
pienso que lo único que le falta es el
premio nobel y si no se lo dieron es
porque es mujer porque hay tal vez
muchos hombres que están en el mismo en
la misma área de investigación pero el
reconocimiento que tiene es algo a mí me
impresionó a conocer su historia y saber
que tienes en 100 años y sigue enseñando
en maquila entonces hay que verlas toda
una mujercita frank lloyd en los vídeos
que yo vi me parece algo extraordinario
y como los investigadores que tiene 40
años 50 años se sienten pequeñitos
frente a ella pues es un monumento a la
ciencia que interesante porque además
esto explica que hay varios tipos de
memoria y por ejemplo esto nos lleva no
sé si les ha pasado que algún momento
por ejemplo yo no recuerdo como dónde va
un acento una palabra y tengo que
escribir la esencia y si la memoria
nemotécnica y si pero además lo que ella
dice es el hecho del ejercicio es lo
motriz
rufo la memoria motriz eso lo que vos
estás hablando es eso también la memoria
motriz
es independiente de otras memorias y eso
fue el gran descubrimiento quizá
entonces eso también nos lleva esta idea
no sé si han escuchado hablar de que hay
recuerdos hay recuerdos generacionales
que son transmitidos por el por el apoyo
por los cromosomas los genes por los
genes y sí sí sí hay hay yo me acuerdo
haber hecho un reportaje sobre una
psicóloga de las primeras naciones de
canadá que justamente investigaba esa
área y ella decía que en la población
actual canadiense está inscrita en los
genes de las primeras naciones todo el
sufrimiento que tuvieron sus padres y
sus abuelos en las escuelas en estas
escuelas donde los los interna van a los
indígenas de las primeras naciones con
todo el sufrimiento que eso acarrea va
entonces si yo que sé si lo demuestran
las investigaciones entonces o habla
ella también hacía un paralelo por
ejemplo entre el holocausto los judíos
de la segunda guerra mundial que también
está inscrito en los genes ese
sufrimiento
entonces lo que vos estás mencionando es
un área de investigación que tiene
muchísima muchísima actualidad y yo creo
que una persona entonces puede entre
comillas recordar algo que vivió una
generación que la precedió no
necesariamente pero sí tener a tener
actitudes que vos no te explicas a veces
porque sos como software hasta que
llegas puedes hacer hasta aquí puedes
descubrir y así se aplican los cambios
generacionales digamos cromosómicos
cuando uno por ejemplo se decía que
íbamos a dejar de tener en algún momento
en nuestro período de evolución vamos a
dejar de tener dedos ciertos dedos del
pie que ya no se usan de la misma manera
que se usaban y eso viene por una
acumulación de usos y que el cuerpo que
la genética se va dando cuenta que ya no
bueno también se da cuenta que hubieron
otras cosas que marcan esa genética y
que no son necesarias no son físicas
louis tú nos hablas ahora de una
entrevista que hiciste con claudia
samayoa exacto sobre los desplazados
exacto claudia samayoa
tuvo días pasados aquí en canadá en
toronto y en otra agua donde se llevó a
cabo un encuentro patrocinado por la
acnur que es la agencia de naciones
unidas para el refugiado que se ocupa
del refugiado y que tuvo como eje
central el tema precisamente de los
desplazados
esas vastas poblaciones a lo largo de
distintos países de américa central y
por supuesto también en otras partes del
mundo pero en este caso específico de
américa central que se mueven entre los
distintos países o inclusive dentro a
veces de los mismos territorios para
buscar una situación mejor y todos
tenemos en nuestra memoria o en nuestra
retina las imágenes recientes de los
inmigrantes llegados a la frontera
mexicano-estadounidense y de la
separación de niños y padres a partir de
las políticas aplicadas por eeuu bueno
en lo que dice claudia samayoa es que
estos desplazamientos que se producen
hoy en día ya no obedecen a razones
económicas como podían como podían ser
las que ocurrían hasta hace un poco
tiempo atrás sino que básicamente están
motivadas por
en enorme ola de violencia que sacude
américa américa central en su conjunto y
que la única forma que tiene esta gente
de escapar a esa gran ola de violencia y
en estabilidad política es buscar su
vida en otros horizontes por eso se
producen estos desplazamientos pero lo
que ella agrega además es que
contrariamente lo que se podría suponer
y más allá de las políticas que han
implementado algunos países a su modo de
eeuu también con el tema de los visados
intentando que llegue menor gente a su
territorio es que la situación lejos de
mejorar tiende a empeorarse y que en el
año 2007 hubo en total 294 mil
desplazados en la zona lo cual implica
un incremento del 58 por ciento respecto
del año precedente ella decía y yo luce
como título de mi entrevista que en la
actualidad tenemos más desplazados que
en la época de la guerra fría cuando
razones políticas provocaban que gente
tuviera que salir de sus países y
dirigirse a otras fronteras y reclama a
su manera una acción por parte de los
gobiernos locales y de la comunidad
internacional porque si no este problema
a seguir agravándose y va a convertirse
en un verdadero flagelo al cual hasta
ahora nadie parece encontrar la solución
de ningún tipo
seguramente y eso también se suma a este
caldo este estudio que se hizo hace poco
en el cual se demostraba que si el mundo
tiene aproximadamente 7 mil millones de
habitantes un poco más y américa latina
tiene entre 400 más de 400 millones de
habitantes que el 30 por ciento por
ventas 30% de los de los de los
homicidios las crímenes se cometía en la
región que es la región más violenta
un poco siguiendo lo que decía luis y yo
también
he leído de que ve por ejemplo estos
centroamericanos que a toda costa
intentan llegar a estados unidos ya no
vienen en busca del sueño americano el
sueño americano de antes que era el auto
comprar llegar a eeuu y te cae la plata
del cielo y de contras autos y vives no
nada no tiene nada que ver es para
salvar de una mujer decías para salvarla
mis hijas de ser violadas es la
supervivencia y buscar una seguridad
para poder vivir tranquilos
y es por eso que decían los analistas no
me acuerdo dónde leí eso de que
justamente va a ser imposible que se
pueda aplicar las medidas que quiere
aplicar trump y eeuu para impedir que
lleguen porque el deseo de esta gente la
idea de esta gente es sobrevivir porque
si se quedan se mueren entonces no va a
haber manera de atajar y esto se refleja
en las cartas que recibimos últimamente
por lo menos en los últimos periodos hay
cartas nicaragüenses de guatemaltecos
dicen bueno me persiguen tensión
políticas y una serie una enorme
cantidad de cartas que seguimos que
justamente reflejan esta esta necesidad
de buscar y buscar la paz en eeuu
en eeuu también no creo que sea
imposible si se puede y en el caso
américa central en su conjunto con
grandes diferencias de un país al otro y
con algunas excepciones también se
encuentra inversa una situación que es
poco propicia para vastas
áreas de la población y lo que samayoa
dice además o agrega es que el siglo 21
se está convirtiendo además en un
retroceso en una pérdida de todas las
conquistas que se habían logrado en
materia de derechos humanos en el siglo
20 se está cayendo en una marcha atrás
en una revisión para anular esas
políticas de avance en materia de
derechos humanos que se habían
conseguido en los últimos 100 años y
podríamos añadir las leyes de trabajo
etcétera etcétera bien estar escuchando
que nada en las américas café en las
elas en el sitio internet de ese punto
sea este programa también está
disponible en facebook en youtube en
nuestro sitio y también en la visión en
la versión audio podríamos escuchar a
las colombianas él ya y elisabeth al
grupo monte al ente de afrobeat a flor
díaz ya los tangueros electrónicos de
tan quieto
ahora pasamos al sitio tengo dos saludos
antes bueno pablo gómez barrios nuestro
colega nos está mirando así que saludos
a él especialmente está de vacaciones
y después tenemos otro mensaje de álvaro
ochoa dicen muy buen programa saludos
desde ottawa y el liberto delicia nos
manda un saludo
beavis and también está revisando baby
sun de dónde será si tengo bien
entendido es inmigrante en canadá
entre uno y uno de teléfonos celulares
plegables bueno si en realidad es un
sueño y como los dobles
yakarta exacto como un libro esa es la
idea por lo menos y esa es la patente
que consiguió con unos detalles bastante
interesantes appo y habló de la patente
puntualmente porque hace un par de
semanas se resolvió una patente que
venía hace diez años luchando sin
justicia entre apple y samsung por bueno
cuestiones que implementando en sus
teléfonos estaban la patente del otro en
este caso para
adelantarse en esta carrera ni tratar de
lograr este teléfono plegable azul logró
la patente que en realidad bien
intentando hacer desde el 2013 que viene
entregando y haciéndose aprobar patentes
con posibilidades de teléfonos plegables
y en este caso bueno hasta apareció una
patente que tiene un proyecto bastante a
conciencia el tema es que todavía no se
sabe si con los materiales que se
disponen hoy se va a poder construir
pero por lo menos el plan está se supone
que si hay alguna versión va a ser para
el año 2020 aproximadamente y ahí
empezaron los analistas que quieren que
tenga esto que quieren que tenga el otro
que quieren que cambia tener eso y lo
pasa es que uno tendría un teléfono que
lo pueda abrir y ya es una especie de
tableta tendría que tener la tableta es
un avance es un avance porque pasan al
teléfono plegable del teléfono es
doblarle si desea tener varios modelos
de teléfonos en el que vistos inclusive
gente aquí en los locales de apple
reclamando porque los teléfonos 087
etcétera con el uso y de ubicado en el
en el bolsillo trasero del pantalón
cuando la gente se sienta
y termina el teléfono con nosotros
el primer teléfono plegaria era del
capitán james t
scotti pero ya habían los teléfonos mayo
tuvimos con momento dado los nokia's por
ejemplar o si los startups de motorola
también eran famosos por los problemas
porque eran aplicables pero este caso lo
que se habla es un teléfono de estas
características plegables que uno abre
así tiene todo pantalla
tener o usarla como una pequeña
computadora en texas se sigue el
teléfono y usted declaró el teléfono
abrió lo puedo usar como teléfono o
abrirlo y tener dos pantallas que lo que
se viene esperando hace ya mucho tiempo
los recuerdos o el futuro luego alvin
toffler que ya en los años 80 hablaba
del teléfono plegable que era una la
minita que no la podía doblar enroscar
este tri ponencia en el bolsillo eso
ahora no llega pero también también el
ipad era ciencia ficción
odisea en espacio y ya está el ipad ahí
hace claros así excel está ahí está
viendo sus noticias en el espacio es
fantasmas ya que steve jobs no inventó
la no neutralidad no no y ahora
recomiendo esta semana un breve un breve
reportaje sobre los indígenas en
saskatchewan que inicien acciones
legales por arrestos y lo que está en
juego son dos visiones o dos versiones
de algo que está ocurriendo en este
momento en regina que es la capital de
esa provincia de saskatchewan donde un
grupo uno empezó una protesta por la
es decisión de los de sistema legal
canadiense de absolver a dos personas
esta ley y ramón con su fueron los dos
hombres blancos absueltos por las
muertes de dos indígenas canadienses
court en bus y abatido con un arma de
fuego y tina font en una niña de 15 años
cuyo cuerpo fue arrojado al red river un
río de esa provincia entonces ese
campamento se llamaba justicia para
nuestros niños robados entonces lo que
la policía trató de desmantelar ese esos
tipos ellos hubo arrestos 6 personas
arrestadas y lo que los abogados de los
indígenas plantean es que ese derecho a
estar allí protestando frente a la
legislación en regina donde están
pidiendo cambios por el excesivo número
de niños indígenas que son sacados
familias y colocados en familias de
acogida y sobre todo del enorme número
de indígenas en el sistema penal cáncer
al de canadá entonces ellos están
pidiendo
reformas en ese sentido y la visión del
gobierno es que ahora van a quieren
buscar una ley que un fallo de la corte
para preservar el parque el parque y
huasca na quieren que el pasto siga
verde entonces dos visiones dos es un
conflicto central en que nada que se
manifiesta de forma tan concreta como el
levantarse y el dirigir estos tipos en
regina saskatchewan que junto con wind
con manitoba son las provincias donde
hay el mayor número de indígenas en
áreas urbanas entonces ese es el tema
que yo les recomiendo para esta semana
yo quería antes de terminar saliendo del
tema de los temas que proponemos para la
semana saludar a la gente en argentina
brasil y perú que hoy están festejando
el día del amigo agua así que nuestros
amigos el 20 de junio en estos tres
países después feliz día el 30 de julio
está digamos como más institucionalizada
la ciudad
cruzada mundial de la amistad pero
particularmente en esos tres países
argentina brasil y perú
hoy el del amigos y que nuestros amigos
oyentes de las tierras saludos y gracias
por el mensaje porque habían llegado
mensaje durante la mañana y yo no sabía
por qué me estaban saludando y 28 de
julio se celebre montreal
el 28 de julio se celebra en montreal no
me acuerdo el 10 del anticucho pero
anticuchos es un pedazo de corazón a la
brasa
porque el 28 de julio la comida peruana
en montreal celebra su aniversario y un
plato típico de montreal entonces pues
tal vez no lo conocía yo entonces hay
mucho en el barrio donde donde luis vive
hay lugares donde sirven estas escuelas
y así me escucho montamos saludos
entonces de nicolás ricos saludos de
monterrey méjico después tenemos a els y
remedy bidart saludos desde brasil feliz
del amigo por día y bueno después los
que habíamos mejorado anteriormente
álvaro ochoa que nos saluda y nos dice
que tenemos un compra bien entonces en
los últimos cinco minutos demos lectura
algunas alguno mensajes de nuestros
oyentes louis yo puedo referir aquí un
mensaje no lo voy a leer porque estaba
un poco complicado la lectura pero eso
que nos envía palomas sin rumbo paloma
sin rumbo es exactamente así firma de
sobre el tema víctimas del tráfico de
personas en canadá contarán su
experiencia parece ser que ella se ha
enamorado de ella es colombiana que se
ha enamorado de alguien que vive en
canadá y que está dispuesta a dejar sus
estudios en la universidad colombiana
para venirse a vivir con esta persona
bien sea a casar y a vivir con esta
persona que reside en canadá a la que
por la por lo que yo entiendo de su
mensaje no conoce demasiado bien
entonces nos pregunta de qué manera ella
puede hacer para saber la vida de él en
este país la hora no sé cómo puede
enterarse de que hace esta persona que
en canadá ni estudiar sus antecedentes
ni mucho menos supongo que sí va a
casarse
debería darse algún tiempito como para
averiguar por su cuenta algunos datos
más o menos conocer un pronunciarlo son
básicamente conocerlo o confiar en el
sexto sentido
que la intuición la intuición de que no
lo conoce y por qué se va a casar con
alguien porque el hecho el hecho mismo
en que en que ya está dudando
es decir que es un mensaje que yo tengo
acá un correo que viene de argentina y
me da la impresión que puede ser alguna
se llama alma es ran ávila y puede ser
que esté terminando la escuela
secundaria ella dice hola buenas tardes
desde escribo desde argentina estoy
comenzando a definir mi carrera que voy
a estudiar me interesa muchísimo la
radio ya que en la escuela hacemos
programas mi pedido es si pueden
enviarme folletos y ustedes o cualquier
cosa que sume a mi cuaderno cualquier
mínimo detalle para mí es esencial para
introducirme en el tema e interiorizar
me en la radio
en fin contemplar cada detalle que me
ayude a fortalecer la elección de una
carrera nosotros desgraciadamente alma
no podemos enviar lo que nos estás
pidiendo pero si quieres un consejo yo
creo que es interesante que escuches
este programa para que veas un poco cómo
sucede durante qué es lo que hacemos
durante un programa
en nuestro sitio visitó argentína además
puede recurrir terminal y será el cos al
dónde le van a dar mucha información su
legítima radio puede empaparse de la
currícula de la carrera de comunicación
social de universidad buenos aires que
es la mejor existen buenos aires y mil
retos del país también hay un montaje
cableras en todo el país carrera de
comunicación en todo el país mendoza es
muy buena rosario muy buena córdoba es
muy buena entre ríos es muy buena tiene
para elegir tiene yo aquí tengo mensajes
dice como son los primeros días de los
solicitantes de refugio en canadá y la
ayuda que reciben y harold rené pérez
nos dice linda la ayuda y protección que
brindan que pesar me da que no sé cómo
hacer para pedir dicho refugio es en el
año 2012
yo recibir refugio los eeuu pero pedí
que me regresaran a mi patria por miedo
aparte mi familia mi madre mis dos hijos
de que matías y mi esposa hoy nuevamente
buscó refugio espero encontrarlo mis dos
hijos mi esposa y mi madre esperan que
tenga éxito y ellos también se pueden
salvar del peligro que los acecha en
este momento y con ese mensaje amigos
llegamos al final de este programa
como siempre un gusto en compartir esto
estos 45 minutos con ustedes recordamos
que tenemos una visión audio en nuestro
sitio de internet con música estuvieron
hoy con ustedes en los micrófonos hoy a
bordo de una hora
leonardo gimeno y quienes a la ruffa
valencia y nos pedimos siempre con el
tema de los espías rusos mexicanos
etcétera etcétera
un saludo y hasta la próxima
siempre un gusto en compartir esto estos
45 minutos con ustedes les recordamos
que tenemos una visión audio en nuestro
sitio de internet com
[Música]